a day after the breach of Ukraine's
largest dam these water levels are still
Rising
rescue workers are helping people to
move to Higher Ground from their homes
close to the danipro river
people here say after the dam exploded
they didn't realize how fast the water
would rise
I kept
sitting I would stay there and then the
water began to run with such force that
well my son thought of it he took a boat
from a neighbor and thanks to this we
got out
Russia and Ukraine have accused each
other of shelling the dam
tens of thousands of people are at risk
in Russian and Ukrainian Health areas
along the river
the Ukrainian company that manages the
dam says it will take days for it to
stop releasing large amounts of water
and that water is flooding hectares of
agricultural land used to supply the
world with grain sunflower oil and other
Foods
for now people are rushing to leave this
area any way they can
for some they're leaving their homes
forever
Barbara and gopa Al Jazeera